♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME ON THE SHOW TALKING ABOUT
IDEOLOGY, WHAT PEOPLE BELIEVE,
BUT IN THE END, THE MEASURE OF A
GOVERNMENT IS NOT ITS IDEAS,
IT'S THE EFFECTS OF ITS POLICY
ON YOU.
CAN YOU WALK AROUND THE MALL
WITHOUT GETTING MUGGED?
CAN YOU SEND YOUR KIDS TO SCHOOL
WITH THE HOPE THAT THEY WILL BE
EDUCATED?
CAN YOU RUN YOUR AIR
CONDITIONING IN THE SUMMER
WITHOUT WORRYING THERE IS GOING
BE A BROWNOUT BECAUSE THE
ELECTRICAL GRID HAS BEEN SO
DEGRADED BY BAD POLICIES?
THOSE ARE THE THINGS, CAN YOU
TAKE A SOUTHWEST AIRLINES FLIGHT
TO GO SEE YOUR FAMILY?
WHEN THOSE THINGS START TO
BECOME IMPOSSIBLE, YOU KNOW
YOU'VE GOT BAD GOVERNMENT.
WELL, OVER THE WEEKEND, A LOT OF
AMERICAN AIR TRAVELERS FOUND OUT
THINGS ARE FALLING APART.
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES CANCELED
PROBABLY HALF THEIR FLIGHTS THIS
WEEKEND.
NOW WHY DID THAT HAPPEN?
WELL, WE TOLD YOU LAST NIGHT THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHY IT HAPPENED, WE
KNOW THE TRUTH BECAUSE WE HAVE
SPOKEN TO PEOPLE DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN IT.
PILOTS AT SOUTHWEST AIRLINES ARE
FACING A VACCINE MANDATE.
OR THEY WILL BE FIRED RIGHT
BEFORE CHRISTMAS IF THEY DON'T
SUBMIT TO MEDICINE THEY DON'T WT
TO TAKE.
A LOT OF THEM HAVE ALREADY
RECOVERED FROM COVID AND DO NOT
NEED THE VACCINE, BUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS FORCING THEM
ANYWAY.
SO THIS WEEKEND, A LOT OF THEM
DID NOT SHOW UP FOR WORK.
THAT USED TO BE CALLED CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE, BUT THAT IS WHAT
IS ACTION HAPPENING.
THAT HAPPENED THIS WEEKEND.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THE FACT VIRTUALLY EVERYONE IN
CHARGE HAS BEEN LYING ABOUT IT
TELLS YOU A LOT.
TELLS YOU ON THE ONE HAND THEY
DO NOT WANT TO OWN UP TO THE
RESULTS OF THEIR POLICIES, THE
RECKLESS, CRAZY POLICIES, WHICH
ARE IN EFFECT A POWER GRAB AND
NOT PUBLIC HEALTH, BUT IT ALSO
TELLS YOU THEY ARE VERY WORRIED
BECAUSE WHEN ORDINARY PEOPLE
REALIZE THEY HAVE POWER, TOO,
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WITH SKILLS,
WHO DO THINGS MOST PEOPLE CAN'T
DO LIKE FLY AIRPLANES OR RUN AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROL CENTERS, THEY
REALIZED BY NOT DOING THOSE
THINGS, THEY CAN BE HEARD, MAYBE
THE GOVERNMENT HAS LESS POWER
THAN THEY THINK THEY DO.
SO FOR THE PAST 24 HOURS, YOU
HAVE SEEN THE USUAL LIARS STAND
UP AND SHOUT US DOWN.
"OH, NO, THAT IS NOT WHAT
HAPPENED!
IT WAS WHETHER THAT SOMEHOW ONLY
AFFECTED SOUTHWEST AIRLINES."
YOU HEARD THE CEO OF SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES GO ON TELEVISION AND
TELL THAT LIE.
HIS NAME IS GARY KELLY, HE IS
UNDER AN AWFUL LOT OF PRESSURE,
SO MAYBE HE HAD TO LIE, BUT HE
DEFINITELY LIED.
HE WENT ON TV TODAY AND SAID OH,
NO, IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
BIDEN'S VACCINE MANDATES.
WATCH.
>> SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE INVEST
IN THIS IDEA THAT IT SOMEHOW
RELATED TO VACCINE MANDATES.
>> THERE IS JUST NO EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
AS I SAID AND AS CAPTAIN MURRAY
SAID, OUR PEOPLE ARE WORKING
VERY HARD.
THEY ARE DOING A GREAT JOB.
I AM VERY PROUD OF THEM, AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE GET INTO
DIFFICULT SITUATION LIKE THIS,
THEY ARE ALSO DELAYED, THEY ARE
ALSO ENDING UP IN PLACES THAT
THEY DIDN'T EXPECT, SO NOW OUR
PEOPLE ARE DOING A PHENOMENAL
JOB.
>> Tucker: YOUR PEOPLE ARE
DOING A PHENOMENAL JOB STANDING
UP FOR WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN THE
FACE OF TYRANNY.
BUT TO SAY THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THIS WEEK THE RESULT OF A DIRECT
REACTION TO JOE BIDEN'S VACCINE
MANDATE IS A LIE, AND YOU KNOW
IT'S A LIE IF YOU KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THE COMPANY YOU'VE GONE,
AND FOR THAT LIST DOES.
LATER IN THE SAME INTERVIEW,
GARY KELLY OF SOUTHWEST MADE IT
CLEAR THAT BIDEN'S MANDATE IS
THE ONLY REASON HE IS FORCING
HIS EMPLOYEES TO GET THE SHOT OR
BE FIRED.
>> THE VACCINE MANDATE OBVIOUSLY
IS CONTROVERSIAL, AND IT IS NOT
ANYTHING I WISH FOR OUR COMPANY.
THIS IS A GOVERNMENT MANDATE.
IT IS A PRESIDENTIAL ORDER.
AND WE ARE DOING OUR BEST TO
COMPLY WITH THAT.
>> Tucker: OH, IT'S A
GOVERNMENT MANDATE.
THAT WILL BE THE SAME GOVERNMENT
THAT IS IGNORING ITS OWN LAWS,
IGNORING FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW
AND ALLOWING THE REST OF THE
WORLD INTO OUR COUNTRY
UNCHECKED.
THAT IS A VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS A
BATTING ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR.
SO FOR THE CEO OF A COMPANY TO
SAY "WE MUST FOLLOW THE LAW" AS
DIRECTED BY AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IS VIOLATING THE LAW ON A
MASS SCALE, IS A LITTLE MUCH,
AND EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
LYING, LYING, LYING.
WELL, GOVERNOR OF TEXAS,
GREG ABBOTT, JUST BAND VACCINE
MANDATES IN HIS STATE.
SOUTHWEST IS HEADQUARTERED IN
TEXAS.
AND YET, SOUTHWEST AND NOW
AMERICAN AIRLINES AND IBM HAVE
ANNOUNCED THEY WILL DEFY
GREG ABBOTT SPAM.
OH, THEY ARE MORE AFRAID OF
JOE BIDEN THEN THEY ARE OF
GREG ABBOTT.
OVER THE WHITE HOUSE, BY THE
WAY, JOE BIDEN'S TOP FLAG IS
DOING WHAT SHE DOES EVERY DAY,
LIE IN, LYING, LYING.
HERE ARE MORE LIES ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT SOUTHWEST.
>> I KNOW THERE WAS A LITTLE
HUBBUB OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST FEW DAYS ABOUT SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES.
WE NOW KNOW THAT SOME OF THOSE
PLANES WERE ABSOLUTELY
FALSE, AND ACTUALLY THE ISSUE WS
CLEARLY UNRELATED TO VACCINE
MANDATES.
>> Tucker: OH, YOU LIVE.
THEY ARE NOT COMPLETELY
UNRELATED TO VACCINE MANDATES.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE WHO CALLED IN
SICK, THEY WERE A DIRECT RESULT
OF THE VACCINE MANDATE.
YOU DID THIS, JOE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE, YOU ARE WRECKING
OUR INTERSTATE TRAVEL SYSTEM.
OVER CHRISTMAS, YOU ARE GOING TO
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEO